[Musik]
wie sieht die wirtschaft der zukunft aus
nun also lange dauert es nicht mehr dann
wissen wir es schon bald explodieren
datenmengen denkt künstliche intelligenz
arbeiten wir mit robotern industrie 4.0
sie wird unser gesamtes
wirtschaftssystem unseren konsum unserer
arbeit stark verändern welche nationen
welche unternehmen in 20 30 jahren die
welt beherrschen
darüber lässt sich nur spekulieren noch
ist man hierzulande stolz auf made in
germany doch bei zukunftsthemen wie it
digitalisierung telekommunikation
dominieren amerikanische und inzwischen
auch chinesische anbieter
sie bestimmen mehr und mehr über unsere
wirtschaft und unser leben
wahrscheinlich auch in zukunft
wirtschaft hieß bisher menschenhandel
menschen haben ein konto menschen
bezahlen menschen aber in der zukunft
gibt es auch eine maschinen ökonomie das
sind milliarden von unterschiedlichen
geräten sensoren handys autos thronen
die man dann nicht nur miteinander
informationen austauschen lässt sondern
die dann auch beginnen
transaktionen auszuüben das heißt eine
maschine überweist geld an eine andere
maschine
damit das reibungslos funktionieren kann
braucht es eine netzwerk technologie die
nicht gehackt werden kann und die vor
allem mit der irren menge an maschinen
und daten zu recht kommt der 21 jährige
dominic china entwickelt derzeit mit
zwei partnern die technologie jutta die
genau das leisten soll also in zehn
jahren sehen wir heute wirklich als als
rückenmark dieser maschine economy also
wir wollen es wirklich möglich dass
maschine sich untereinander bezahlen
durch diesen jutta standard
das besondere dieser jutta technologie
je mehr maschinen teilnehmen desto
schneller und sicherer soll sie sein
treffen mit dem chief digital officer
von volkswagen kein zufall denn eine
reihe deutscher dax-konzerne
interessiert welche wirtschaftlichen
chancen technologien wie jutta in der
zukunft bieten wenn diese fahrzeuge dann
halt menschen und waren von a nach b
transportieren wenn sie dann
selbstständig sozusagen vielleicht als
unternehmer handeln ja und auch einfach
den besten preis aushandeln selbständig
für das parkhaus fürs laden fürs parken
und so weiter bezahlen
es werden milliarden transaktionen
sozusagen sein pro tag
und dafür braucht man sichere technik
und da muss ich sagen wenn ich diese
lösung also hoch spannend konzerne wie
vw oder auch der elektroriese bosch
wissen längst dass aber millionen
sensoren jetzt schon in maschinen daten
sammelt mal einen schritt weiter gedacht
was ist wenn man die daten die man zum
beispiel im netz hinterlässt wenn man
die einfach selber verkauft ein gutes
beispiel ist beispiel facebook welches
ungefähr zwischen 1000 und 2000 euro pro
jahr nur mit deinen daten verdient weil
sie wie möglich nichts wichtig dass
diese ganze wertschöpfungskette von den
daten dass die auch den eigenen
eigentlichen daten besitzern auch
zukommt das heißt dass du in zukunft in
der lage bist mit den daten die durch
steine generiert auch geld zu verdienen
maschinen werden menschen immer
ähnlicher sie schaffen daten sie handeln
miteinander sie kommunizieren und lernen
voneinander
wenn der mensch aber maschinen erfindet
die ihm immer ähnlicher werden muss sich
der mensch selbst neu erfinden
ob internet der dinge big data
künstliche intelligenz die technik der
zukunft wird unsere gesellschaft
wirtschaft arbeit verändern
aber was kommt da auf uns zu
zukunft war gestern heute geht es darum
mehrere zukünfte zu durchdenken und
darauf basierend bessere entscheidungen
zu treffen und das ist das was wir im
masterstudiengang vermitteln
alexander fink ist zukunftsforscher
schwerpunkt szenario management er
unterrichtet an der fau berlin hier geht
es nicht um einfache hochrechnungen und
big data ob delphi methode leitbild
analyse oder design thinking die
zukunftsforschung verwendet methoden
verschiedener wissenschaftlicher
disziplinen auch beim szenario
management es ist natürlich wichtig dass
man erst mal einen breiten radarschirm
hat dass man sich nicht nur auf einzelne
bereiche fokussiert sondern die eigene
branche das eigene themenfeld genauso
einbezieht wie übergeordnete entwicklung
und dann sind im grunde genommen drei
phasen man macht sich gedanken was die
wesentlichen sagen wir mal fragen an die
zukunft sind die sogenannten
schlüsselfaktoren um dann im zweiten
schritt zu überlegen wie die sich
entwickeln könnten also die alternativen
zu beschreiben und diese alternativen
die bilden dann wieder die bausteine aus
denen szenarien zusammengesetzt werden
wer einmal die methode richtig gelernt
hat kann sie auf alle möglichen bereiche
anwenden politik gesellschaft wirtschaft
für alle themen können mögliche zukünfte
entworfen werden
ich glaube dass das ein sehr sehr
breites feld mittlerweile ist wir merken
das ja auch an denjenigen die bei uns
zukunftsthemen nachfragen das sind
natürlich unternehmen
das sind aber nicht mehr nur die großen
unternehmen das sind auch
mittelständische unternehmen
das sind auch öffentliche institutionen
das können regierungen sein das können
organisationen seien und es gibt ja auch
im
zivilgesellschaftlichen bereich viele
fragestellungen die sicherlich
sinnvoller weise etwas mehr
zukunftsorientierung vertragen könnten
was heute noch heiß diskutiert wird wie
ist 2035 vielleicht gar kein thema mehr
was genau auf der agenda steht
zukunftsforscher fink will sich da nicht
festlegen
also ich glaube das ist einfach themen
gibt die ganz stark auf die agenda
kommen
und so wie man heute allerorten über
digitalisierung spricht und etwas
technologisches meint in der regel wird
glaube ich die technologie ein stück in
den hintergrund rücken und es werden
andere fragen aufkommen das wird was mit
klimawandel zu tun haben das wird aber
auch etwas mit dem wirtschaftssystem zu
tun haben das wird etwas mit der frage
zu tun haben wie welche rolle arbeit
eigentlich spielt in der zukunft und
dann werden ist es notwendig diese
themen auch zusammen zu denken mensch
und maschine müssen in zukunft
zusammengedacht werden für unsere
arbeitswelt wird technik eine immer
größere rolle spielen
der mitarbeiter von heute soll stets
bereit sein sich zu verändern sich immer
wieder anzupassen an die neuen
herausforderungen der globalen
wirtschaft und der mitarbeiter der
zukunft der wird es wahrscheinlich noch
schwerer haben denn er oder sie hat
einen konkurrent mehr auf dem
arbeitsmarkt roboter oder computer
übernehmen immer mehr arbeiten in allen
möglichen bereichen der geschafft da hat
man keine angst um seinen job
doch der wandel schafft auch neue berufe
wir haben gelernt zu lernen und sie
können mit anderen robotern
kommunizieren
faszinierend doch viel macht das angst
intelligente roboter die unsere arbeit
übernehmen ist das die zukunft der neue
kollege von industriemechaniker brandl
kann zwar nicht sprechen ist aber ein
fleißiger helfer um seinen job muss er
sich keine sorgen machen denn mit kubot
arbeitet er hand in hand
die arbeiten hierzu eine ideale wahl zum
teil ergonomisch nicht gerade gut sage
ich jetzt mal um die nimmt uns der
roboter entlastet uns dabei körperlich
industrie 4.0 steht für automatisierung
und digitalisierung für maschinen die
mitdenken und facharbeiter die neue
technologien ausprobieren sowie bei
smart factory die mechanikerin erhält
über die daten brille die nächsten
arbeitsschritte eingeblendet eine
vernetzung von realer und virtueller
welt viele vorher noch nie auch klar man
spielt früher mal wieder spieler aber
diese brille hatte ich selbst nie auf
und ja es macht schon spaß
die produktionszeiten haben sich in den
letzten drei jahren halbiert job killer
roboter noch ist das nicht eingetreten
denn das unternehmen hat bei den
verkaufszahlen zugelegt firmen die
wachsen können ihre arbeitsplätze
sichern
aber nicht alle klar ist aber auch dass
die berufe die schon jetzt sehr stark
computer basiert sind und die sehr hoch
standardisierten in einem hohem umfang
standardisiert sind dass diese berufe
sehr anfällig sind ersetzt zu werden in
zukunft in der metallbranche erledigen
roboter oder computer schon heute über
80 prozent der tätigkeiten auch
elektroniker und becker sieht es düster
aus
im finanzwesen können computer fast 70
prozent aller aufgaben selbstständig
lösen
insgesamt können 1,5 millionen
arbeitsplätze bis 2025 wegfallen
er rechnet das institut für arbeitsmarkt
und berufsforschung
es wird ganz entscheidend davon abhängig
sein ob es uns gelingt die
digitalisierung
eben nicht nur technik zentriert
voranzutreiben also danach zu fragen was
ist technisch machbar sondern gelingt es
uns diesen prozess zu steuern zu
gestalten und den menschen dabei in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen
der nächste geplante schritt bei eur 3
die vernetzung mit kunden und
lieferanten maschinen sollen bald
eigenständig nachschub bestellen oder
vorrätige waren an den kunden melden und
die mitarbeiter lebenslanges lernen ist
angesagt der mitarbeiter der zukunft
muster bereit sein sich auch immer
wieder zu verändern sich anzupassen an
die neuen herausforderungen dieser zeit
20 milliarden produkte und geräte sollen
im jahr 2020 über das internet direkt
miteinander kommunizieren
das wird unsere arbeit radikal verändern
die industrie 4.0 ist das hier jetzt
eigentlich schon die arbeit an der
industrie 4.0
wir haben ja wir können bestenfalls
davon sprechen dass es ein demonstrator
ist oder eine experimentier umgebung
dessen weil sie in zukunft auch in den
produktionshallen deutschlands erwarten
wird okay was haben wir denn hier zum
beispiel das sieht mir
nach einem teil einer produktionsjahr
dass das werden sie kennen das ist
einfach ein akkuschrauber der in dem
fall allerdings ergonomisch gerecht von
der decke hängt weil sie damit gewohnt
sind als montagearbeiter in den vielen
montage arbeitsplätzen der deutschen
industrie etwas festzuschrauben zu
bohren oder oder oder
was neues in zukunft der industrie 40
werde ich nicht ihr kollege sein dem sie
sagen reicht auch mal gerade den
vormontierten body von beispielsweise
einen solchen getriebe was wir hier
haben sondern der kollege wird dann in
zukunft so sieht die technik im moment
aus dieser roboter seite sein also ein
work mit kollege roboter der eigene
handgriffe und das mit kg unterstützt
auch zunehmend lernend so voll führen
können dass wir mehr und sie dann
wunderbar miteinander arbeiten können
und dinge vormontiert sie dann mit dem
akkuschrauber oder mit anderen
werkzeugen die wir gewohnt sind
einzusetzen als menschen
das werkstück fertigstellt und was ist
jetzt das besonders schwierige daran ich
habe jetzt vielleicht komme ich mit
meinem kollegen ja schon nicht so recht
aber wie gut komme ich denn zu recht mit
dem roboter also sprich das
zusammenspiel von maschine und mensch
auf so engem raum was sind die größten
schwierigkeiten die einen technisch zu
erwarten
tatsache ist das ist genau der punkt die
technische arbeit oder die robotik und
menschliche arbeit werden in zukunft
stärker miteinander verschmelzen
wir haben bis jetzt eine strikte
trennung das automatisierte arbeitsgänge
beispielsweise schweißroboter wie wir
sie aus der automobilindustrie kennen
und montagetätigkeiten oder andere
tätigkeiten des menschen sind strikt
getrennt durch schutzzäune das ist hier
nicht mehr der fall das sind sogenannte
light weight robots wie der name schon
sagt wiegen sie nicht so viel können
auch nicht so viel tragen und bewegen
sich in einer geschwindigkeit die
ungefährlich sein muss für den menschen
das ist aber gleichzeitig auch wieder
die krux an der sache weil wenn wir gut
miteinander harmonieren und gut
eingespielt sind
aber dann schnell arbeiten wie immer
schneller und dann steigt ihre
frustration bezogen auf einen solchen
roboter weil er irgendwann nicht schnell
genug ist und der mensch dann dazu neigt
also mit dem werkzeug komme ich jetzt
nicht klar dass lediglich zur seite ich
mache lieber selbst und an den
fragestellungen forschen wir hier wie
können menschliche arbeit und solche
automatisch unterstützte künstlich
intelligente arbeit der zukunft
funktionieren
ein stückchen weiter denken dann reden
wir auch davon sogar dass solche
maschinen künstlich intelligent also
lernend mit maschinell munter
maschinellem lernen unterstützt ihre
bewegungsabläufe anpassen
zum zweiten müssen wir aber auch jetzt
schon darüber nachdenken was ist
eigentlich mit der ganzen emotionalen
intelligenz des menschen
wenn ich jetzt heute schlecht drauf bin
und ich arbeite langsamer und wir sind
ein team
dann erwarte ich von ihrer empathie sie
rücksicht darauf nehmen dass ich
schlecht geschlafen habe oder unter
heuschnupfen leidet wie ich das ständig
tue dann ist diese art von aufeinander
zugehen und miteinander die arbeit auch
kombinieren etwas anderes als das was
ich im moment noch von solchen maschinen
erwarten kann es ist also für den
roboter schwer zu lernen mit den
menschen umzugehen
der mensch muss sich auf die maschine
einstellen der normale arbeiter von dem
wird ja dann auch im prinzip erwartet
wenn die maschine sehr viel dazu lernt
dass der mensch auch immer mehr dazu
lernt jetzt haben wir heutzutage schon
ziemlich hohen fachkräftemangel
wenn die berufe immer mehr
qualifizierung benötigen was erwartet
uns denn dann 20 30 zum beispiel das
kommt darauf an wie sie unter mehr
qualifizierung verstehen ist es mehr im
sinne von quantität oder mehr im sender
von qualität
ich stehe auf dem standpunkt dass wir
die herausforderungen die technische
entwicklung mit sich bringt auch
menschen gerecht und lernen gerecht
gestalten müssen also die usability so
gestaltet sein muss das programmieren
kein hexenwerk mails wenn man auf die
bildschirme der programmierer schaut
blickt man nicht durch sondern es muss
so sein dass jeder ist
bei den handwerksberuf gelernt hat auch
programmieren kann in dem maße wie es
für seine arbeitsumgebung nötig ist
und da sind wir eigentlich auf einem
guten weg auch von der software her
software her und von der usability
entwicklung in so eine richtung zu gehen
und das wird auch die chance sein müssen
weil ansonsten wird der fachkräftemangel
sehr viel schlimmer sein als die
arbeitsplätze die wir vielleicht
verlieren durch solche automatisierungs
elemente wie wir sie hier sehen dann
schauen wir noch einmal sondern die
zukunft führen wir hier schon das modell
haben für die industrie 4.0
was meinen sie ist der nächste schritt
also auf deutsch wie sieht die industrie
5.0 denn aus fünf punkte und ich dachte
es geht vielleicht wieder zurück zur 3.0
ja also die industrie 450 würde ich mir
so vorstellen dass diese maschinen von
denen wir jetzt sagen wir bringen ihnen
ganz mühsam das lernen bei vielleicht
irgendwann so schlau sind so intelligent
dass sie uns arbeitsschritte vorschlagen
und sagen kollege hieß machen sie das
doch mal
in einer anderen weise nehmen sie die
linke hand und mit der rechten können
sie schrauben da bin ich gespannt wie
der mensch darauf reagiert dass an
bestimmten stellen des technisches
system bessere ideen bessere vorschläge
hat als ich selbst weil das ist ja eine
demütigung für meine intelligenz
emotionale intelligenz kognitive
intelligenz darüber zu philosophieren in
richtung industrie für neue das ist eine
spannende frage wie sich die
digitalisierung auf den arbeitsmarkt
auswirkt ist noch nicht absehbar in
vielen bereichen dürfte es aber zum
verlust von arbeitsplätzen kommen im
handwerk kann die digitalisierung aber
auch einen mehrwert schaffen ohne dass
es dabei zu jobverlusten kommt der
mensch hat es selbst in der hand
eine erkenntnis die im backhaus
fickentscher seit 1625 reift wie ein
guter sauerteig eine revolution annehmen
heißt nicht sich zu unterwerfen
digitalisierung kann vieles vereinfachen
auch hier ein brot einzigartig machen
kann sie nicht dann brauche ich
eigentlich den menschen der eigentlich
den teig am teig knetet und merkt mensch
da muss sich etwas gesteigert
oder da muss sich etwas mehr wasser
hinzufügen digitalisierung dort wo sie
den bäcker nutzt anstatt ihn zu ersetzen
früher wurden solche arbeiten mitten in
der nacht erledigt heute geht das zu den
normalen arbeitszeiten digitale reife
räume übernehmen die nachtschicht
jetzt zum einen können die bäcker über
die zeit mehr geschmack bilden das heißt
wir haben da einen qualitätssprung und
auf der anderen seite her können wir 70
der nachtarbeit auf den tag verlegen
digitalisierung kann einen mehrwert
schaffen ohne auf den menschen zu
verzichten
nicht jeder handwerksbetrieb sieht das
so eine umfrage des kompetenzzentrums
digitales handwerk zeigt nur 22 prozent
der firmen investieren in die
digitalisierung
es ist natürlich auch in der
altersstruktur der inhaber zu finden
dass manche eben sich damit nicht mehr
beschäftigen wollen weil sie sorgen
das kann ihr nachfolger dann erst
einführen
er will damit nicht oder sie will damit
nichts mehr zu tun haben das backhaus
fickentscher hat also einen wichtigen
schritt vollzogen der vielen anderen
noch bevorsteht und gezeigt tradition
und fortschritt müssen kein widerspruch
sein so ein drittel der menschen in 20
30 jahren werden heute noch nicht wissen
wie ihr beruf dann heißen wird es wird
eine unzahl von neuen berufen geben ein
drittel wird ungefähr von künstlicher
intelligenz abgelöst und das restliche
drittel wird wahrscheinlich sehr
konventionell arbeiten weil menschen
auch an arbeitsplätzen im klassischen
industriellen sind sehr gerne festhalten
er war autor journalist unternehmer vor
über 20 jahren gründete matthias horx
das zukunftsinstitut er ist experte in
sachen arbeit der zukunft im büro nine
to five vielleicht auf 45 jahre beim
selben arbeitgeber für die zukunft
völlig undenkbar
das würde ich so nicht sagen also wir
haben ja erlebt dass es gegen jeden
trend auch im gegentrend gibt und wir
haben vor 20 jahren kann ich meine wir
haben viel für große deutsche banken in
frankfurt gearbeitet in der personal
vision ehrung also wie wird man in
zukunft arbeiten alles was ihr damals
gesagt haben ist nur teilweise
eingetreten
und zwar deshalb weil es ein unheimlich
cs paarung vermögen gibt auch von
menschen selbst also ich glaube es wird
auch in zwanzig dreißig vierzig jahren
immer noch eine menge leute geben die
sich an ihren schreibtischen
festklammern
komme was wolle sie werden
wahrscheinlich weniger verdienen
aber die eigentlich so diese industrien
arbeitsbedarf so verinnerlicht haben das
ist halt ein unheimlich tiefes nehmen ja
also das ist ein kultur musste was wir
so leicht nicht wegreden das wird eben
diese verschiedenen interessen die jetzt
nennt es mal die generation y jetzt hin
zugeschrieben werden also sprechen
schwierig meine arbeit verwirklichen
verdienst ist nicht alles ich will
kreativ sein ich will flexibel sein und
so weiter welche auswirkungen wird das
am ende auch auf die wirtschaft in
deutschland oder auch in der ganzen welt
haben denn die leute anders arbeiten
wollen gerne ja das wird eben dazu
führen dass wir ganz andere biografien
sie sein müssen auch wir brauchen auch
andere sicherheitssysteme über die
könnte man ja mal nachdenken also wie
könnte man zum beispiel unruhige
biografie verläuft in der arbeit wie
könnte man die absichern und dass wir
eine ähnliche form mit denen man
experimentieren kann das können ja
genossenschaftliche form sein wie wir in
andere firmenkonstrukt befinden also er
treibt er genossenschaften
all das ist glaube ich längst auch auf
dem weg weil diese alternative die wir
bis jetzt gehabt haben bayern
lohnabhängiger und da geht es immer um
sicherheit aber auch um abhängigkeit
oder ich muss unternehmer werden dann
muss ich mein leben opfern er muss sich
also 14 stunden arbeiten familie ist
dann eben nicht drin
und diese unheimlich vielen wo sie
liegen zwischen mischform die man in
einer stadt wie frankfurt oder in einer
stadt wie berlin oder hamburg oder
münchen findet diese ja interessant da
ist ja die wirtschaftliche dynamik und
digitalisierung technische innovation
welche berufe werden ihrer meinung nach
nun auf zusätzliche entstehen und welche
werden dann vielleicht auch wegfallen an
anderer stelle in den letzten zehn
jahren sind ungefähr 5.000 neue berufe
stand die man teilweise gar nicht kennt
ja das reicht vom milch analytiker bis
zum allen varianten von von wellness und
yoga angeboten kann man alle aufzählen
bis hin zum hass moderator ja es gibt in
deutschland 3000 hass moderatorin die
versuche den hass aus dem internet
rauszukriegen werden überwiegend von
facebook bezahlt ein furchtbarer job
auch übrigens schlecht bezahlt aber
natürlich mit einem starken karriere
weil es das will
wir werden das gar nicht
alles hinbekommen also wir haben auf der
einen seite von wiederholbaren berufen
aber auch ein bisschen mehr im
kognitiven ich bin nicht so sehr
überzeugt dass jeder buchhalter oder
auch ihre telefon ist abgelöst wird
durch die künstliche intelligenz da bin
ich ein bisschen skeptisch
aber da haben wir verluste aber
gleichzeitig entwickelt sich eine
explodierende neuer bereich von 19 vor
allen dingen servicedienstleistung aber
auch in den fabriken ist ja ein großer
irrtum dass die hoch automatisierten
fabriken menschenleer sind die menschen
sind noch nicht im gebäude sondern darum
herum er hat es und servicetechniker ist
ein computertechniker das sind aber auch
service people
und insofern ist glaube ich auch diese
ganze hektik und hysterie die wir uns
immer gemacht haben weil der mensch wird
überflüssig in der arbeitswelt wie das
pferd und 19 solche sätze kann ich mich
noch vor 20 jahren erinnern glaube ich
habe ich das wahrscheinlich selber
gesagt
aber so ist es nicht seit beginn der
industriellen revolution sind ja immer
arbeits tätigkeiten sehr schnell auch zu
ende gegangen nur wie wir damit zum
beispiel umgehen das 150 tausend
lastwagen verarbeiten deutschland wenn
das passieren würde dass wir wirklich
automatisch fahrende lastwagen haben
das ist natürlich eine große
herausforderung ein großer teil von
denen wird auch sicherlich in der ferne
kontrolle unterkommen können also das
wird einfach level ab 1
wir sind doch nicht mehr im cockpit
sondern in einem virtuellen cockpit aber
es am ende ist auch der schlüssel die
zahl der arbeitsplätze einigermaßen
gleich zu halten
er findet es ja immer nur die bildung
soll man sich immer nochmal eine stufe
höher setzen muss um das was audi
amortisiert wurde noch zu kontrollieren
da er gleichzeitig ist natürlich ein
mechanisches modell weil wir wissen gar
nicht wie lange arbeiten werden in
zukunft es wird viele menschen geben die
sagen den stumpfen maximal in der woche
mehr will ich gar nicht das mache ich
dann aber hochkonzentriert wir haben es
heute super mitarbeitern in meinem
betrieb da jetzt leute die also
alleinerziehende mütter kann unheimlich
produktiv sein weil die beide sehr
fokussiert sind also in verschiedenen
lebensphasen denn auch die arbeitszeiten
vielmehr differieren die männer können
auch in skandinavien geht alles schon
auf 1 30 stunden arbeitstag von männern
und frauen raus die frauen behandeln
wenn er sich auch um die kinder kommen
dann geht es gar nicht
also da gibt es dann auch plötzliche
sprünge in zeit economy also ist das
interessanteste aber auch absurd ist das
natürlich der acht stunden zu halten
man hatte in skandinavien hat man zwei
stunden abgeschafft werden sie auch auf
sechs stunden runter gegangen und dann
hat man die produktivität gemessen und
die ist eher gestiegen
und das ist natürlich was bedeutet dass
das heißt dass die im 50
in wirklichkeit ganz andere dinge tun
wenn sie auf und so genannten
arbeitsplätze wie lange wir arbeiten
werden wird natürlich auch davon
abhängen wo und mit wem wir arbeiten
werden also welche rolle maschinen
roboter und künstliche intelligenz in
unseren späteren beruf spielen in vielen
bereichen wird der mensch wahrscheinlich
bald ersetzt intelligente technologien
in operationssälen in der kunst auf dem
mars und die frage wer bringt den
maschinen bei was sie dürfen und was
nicht okay
red
[Musik]
zukunftsfantasie vielmehr der wendepunkt
in unserer kulturgeschichte maschinen
den menschen so nah traum oder albtraum
es könnte unser traum sein aber es ist
sehr viel wahrscheinlicher dass es zum
albtraum wird die gesellschaft in der
meine kinder aufwachsen werden steht auf
dem spiel es einfach geschehen zu lassen
führt zur ungleichheit in größte maße
arbeitslosigkeit durch automatisierung
der angstraum unserer zeit
in den usa könnten 20 bis 30 prozent der
jobs durch maschinen ersetzt werden
wer sind wir wenn wir so einfach
ersetzbar sind
im juli in brooklyns hafenviertel hier
geht es um maschinen aber ohne den
menschen geht es hier trotzdem nicht
seit 1983 arbeite ich daran alle
möglichen aufgaben zu automatisieren
die bislang von menschen gemacht wurden
am wichtigsten sind dabei die
anwendungen die gefährliche aufgaben
betreffen oder in widrigen umgebungen
statt
stephen collins erfindungen fliegen seit
jahren mit der nasa zum mars und auch in
der medizin werden sie eingesetzt
antriebskraft das ausloten des machbaren
die gefahr die von künstlicher
intelligenz ausgeht ist nicht neu
in den 80ern wurde mir diese frage immer
gestellt
aber ich habe auch immer gesagt habt
keine angst davor dass wir die kontrolle
über ki verlieren wir werden immer die
herren sein und sie wird zu unserem wohl
arbeiten
davon war ich zu 100 prozent überzeugt
ich muss zugeben
heute bin ich mir da nicht mehr so
sicher es könnte alles verändern so wie
damals die erfindung der elektrizität
darin sind sich die experten einig und
auch dass die entwicklung nicht
aufzuhalten ist der krieg gegen die
normalen leute so lautet der titel von
andrew youngs neuem buch frei übersetzt
welche rolle hat der mensch in einer
welt in der nur die roboter arbeiten
2020 will jan us präsident werden
wir müssen über werte und menschliches
leben anders nachdenken
wir müssen aufhören die menschen nur als
wirtschaftsfaktor wahrzunehmen und zu
sagen wenn der markt sie als wertvoll
einschätzt dann sind sie großartig
und wenn der markt sagt sie seien
wertlos dann sind sie schrecklich es ist
aber eine frage von kunst philosophie
kultur
wie sollten wir in kunst investieren sie
sollten menschen ihre zeit verbringen
was ist uns wichtig
die debatte um künstliche intelligenz
trifft ins herz aller disziplinen
grenzen dazwischen verschwinden und
genau das ist die gefahr forschung darf
nicht nur von wirtschaft bestimmt werden
und menschsein nicht nur eine frage der
intelligenz sein
meine sorge ist dass die rechenleistung
der computer so mächtig wird und so viel
schneller wird als ich jemals gedacht
hätte
und dazu wird sie noch mobil eines tages
könnten sehr gefährliche künstliche
intelligenz systeme in die hände von
kleinen gruppen oder individuen geraten
dann könnte jemand der uns böses will
ein ki system nutzen und wir hätten kein
sicherheitssystem das uns vor ihm
schützen
[Musik]
den menschen schützen vor seine eigenen
kreation künstliche intelligenz ein
wendepunkt vergleichbar mit der
entwicklung der atombombe werden wir
diesmal mehr verantwortung zeigen und
haben wir unsere zukunft überhaupt noch
in der hand
wir müssen uns dessen bewusst werden was
uns zum menschen macht und dass auch
wertschätzen
es ist unglaublich aber das ist der
punkt an dem wir gerade als gesellschaft
stehen
das ist keine science fiction das ist
real und steht uns direkt bevor es
könnte ein traum sein vorausgesetzt wir
wachen rechtzeitig auf
[Musik]
er jeden hier bei automatisierung ist
eine strategie um kosten zu sparen
gewinne zu optimieren und manchmal auch
den dingen ein bisschen leichter zu
machen
aber es gibt einen punkt wo genug
automatisiert worden ist und wo wir
keinen weiteren wirklichen nutzen freude
oder auch unternehmenskultur
mit automatisierung weiter fördern
können und genau da muss man etwas
machen ihren blog nennt sie die ethische
maschine sarah spiekermann betont das
positive der technologisierung will weg
von düsteren zukunftsvisionen
technologischer fortschritt als
persönlicher fortschritt das ist ihr
ziel
künstliche intelligenz wird hier ein
sehr großes thema sein was die
gesellschaft in den nächsten jahren
beschäftigen wird die meisten prognosen
was das angeht sind ja eher düsterer art
sind sie eher pessimistisch oder
optimismus diese entwicklung angeht also
zunächst einmal glaube ich dass die
künstliche intelligenz komplett
überschätzt wird
der grund dafür ist dass maschinen
learnings war exzellent ist um
geschlossene kleinere kontexte wie
schachspielen oder netzoptimierung und
zu bewerkstelligen aber diese idee in
diese versprechungen das jetzt also uns
humanoide roboter mit einer
menschenähnlichen kein intelligenz
entgegentreten
das ist sehr naiv und das ist etwas was
eben durch science fiction in unser
leben ja was unsere fantasie so
berauscht dass wir diesen ideen
eigentlich glauben schenken aber
technisch ist das glaube ich dass rücken
sicherlich nicht so kommen also das ist
genau so ein hype cycle wie big data und
cloud und wir hassen nicht gesehen was
wir alles schon durchlaufen das ist halt
eine super marketing strategie von der
von der 1 das trägt aber die künstliche
intelligenz wird sich insbesondere auf
unsere arbeitswelt auswirkt
also schon jetzt ist es ja so dass
roboter immer mehr tätigkeiten
übernehmen die vorher von menschen
ausgeführt werden wurden
was sehen sie dafür entwicklung also was
für ein verhältnis werden mensch und
maschine
vielleicht schon in 20 jahren zueinander
haben diese art von automatisierung die
finden ist ein permanenter prozess und
die existiert aber vor allen dingen
deswegen weil es dahinter ein
ökonomisches prinzip das ökonomische
prinzip das eigentlich durch
automatisierung in der regel zumindest
mitte kurze mittelfristig kosten gespart
werden
und wenn wir in dieser art von
kapitalmarkt logik bleiben wohl nur das
belohnt wird was maximale gewinne und
minimale kosten eigentlich oder mit
maximale gewinne auch durch minimale
kosten und viele versprechungen
generiert dann wenn man in dieser
ökonomischen logik drin bleibt dann ist
die automatisierung mit partieller
koppelung von karin es ist nicht sehr
schön das ist
es ist sehr sehr fragwürdig ob unsere
gesellschaften sich das antun möchte und
ich weiß auch nicht genau was ist das
soll außerdem das natürlich ein paar
ganz ganz wenige richtig viel geld
verdienen aber wir haben ja wir haben ja
und wir haben es ja auch im moment mit
politischen umbrüchen zu tun
also wenn man wenn man in berlins und
offen darüber diskutiert ob man jetzt
also wohnungen wieder verstaatlicht oder
gelb besten die politik sprengen und
rapper die cdu zuschlagen wollen dann
sind wir eigentlich in einer
interessanten umbruchphase und da glaube
ich zum beispiel nicht dass man mal
einfach so
millionen von menschen durch
automatisierung weiter auf die straße
setzen kann
dann brechen ja auch unsere
sozialsysteme weg also die politiker
möchte ich mal sehen die sich das antun
rechnen wenn jetzt aber unternehmen nach
maximalem gewinnstreben und die sollen
unternehmen dazu gebracht werden sich
politisch korrekt zu verhalten gibt es
verschiedene hebel der erste hebe ist
der politische hebel
das heißt der regierungen haben durchaus
die möglichkeit die zeitlich die
zeitfenster und die konditionen der
automatisierung und die besteuerung der
automatisierung es gibt sehr viele
politische instrumente die beeinflussen
können wie und wo und in welchem ausmaß
automatisiert wird das ist dass der eine
zweite hebel ist der ökonomische hebel
auf der einen seite werden natürlich
kosten gespart aber in der
betriebswirtschaftslehre gibt es
tatsächlich unterschiedliche strategien
in unternehmen erfolgreich zu machen und
das eine ist kosten entspannendes andere
ist qualität erhöhen
und was wir nicht wissen ist wohl der
grad der optimalen automatisierung
aufhört es gibt einen optimalen grad der
automatisierung und es gibt einen punkt
wo automatisierung zu kosten der
qualität gehen und auch zu kosten der
unternehmenskultur
und genau da ist eben ein unternehmen
gar nicht unbedingt gut aufgestellt wenn
es zu sehr automatisiert und der dritte
hebel ist natürlich der markt selbst
also sofern wir noch an einigermaßen
funktionierende märkte glauben haben
auch verbraucher die möglichkeit mit zu
entscheiden welche dienste
fragen die totale vernetzung unserer
wirtschaft wird auch für die konsumenten
vieles ändern
die digitalisierung hat längst unseren
alltag erreicht immer mehr wird im
internet gekauft innenstädte sterben aus
die stationären händler probieren vieles
um den einkauf wieder zum erlebnis zu
machen um die kunden zurückzugewinnen
wie werden wir in zukunft einkaufen
das ist eine interessante frage denn es
wird sich sehr vieles ändern bei unserem
einkauf sicher ist nämlich zum beispiel
auch dass unser einkauf beginnt schon
bevor wir den job überhaupt betreten
haben nämlich hier im wohnzimmer in der
sogenannten prisdorf phase frau kommt
das ist eine prisdorf phasen
es ist gar nicht so kompliziert wie es
klingt was wir damit sagen wollen ist
dass das einkaufen heutzutage nicht nur
in einem supermarkt beispielsweise
stattfindet sondern auch auf dem
heimischen sofa alles ist miteinander
vernetzt wo bringt mich das hin
ja wir haben halt viel mehr touchpoints
zur verfügung ein touch point ist ein
kundenkontakt punkt also wo hat ein
kunde kontakt mit produkten
beispielsweise und das ist möglich durch
die unterschiedlichen geräte die wir
haben unsere smartphones unsere tablets
oder auch der kühlschrank der demnächst
selbstständig das essen bestellt um das
kaufverhalten der zukunft zu simulieren
stehen mir zwei datenbasierte shopper
typen zur auswahl
studentin julia anspruchsvoll will
hochwertiges und regionale produkte
familienvater michael kaufmann im
angebot oder beim discounter
dies wird mein avatar willkommen in
meiner küche
entschuldigen sie für mich ist das heute
noch ein bisschen früh aber zum glück
habe ich zu meinem digitalen assistenten
toni welche termine habe ich heute um 17
uhr ist ein treffen mit herrn peters im
haus der wirtschaft angesetzt und nicht
vergessen 19 uhr kommen claudia und
frank zum essen
das wird sie heute alles ganz schön
knapp ich muss ja auch noch einkaufen
und kochen gut mein avatar redet jetzt
er mit seiner assistentin in dem fall
anstatt mit seiner frau wird sich so die
zukunft anfühlen er sagen wir es mal so
also ein assistent wieder toni hier ist
natürlich auch in zukunft sehr nützlich
kann rezeptvorschläge geben wenn michael
nicht weiß was er kochen soll
und dann muss michael ja auch noch
losgehen und die zutaten einkaufen und
dann wäre es halt praktisch zu wissen
dass michael überhaupt noch an
lebensmitteln zu hause hat und es darf
auch das weißt du nie schneller als der
michael okay wenn er schon so viel weiß
der assistent also ich hätte früher
einfach nur im kühlschrank reingeguckt
ich gucke gerne mal was hier ist weil
mich würde interessieren woher weiß der
assistentin alles genauso wir haben
ihren integriertes system das heißt
dieser assistent toni ist einmal nahtlos
mit einem kamerasystem verbunden man
sieht hier zwei kameras die es möglich
machen die kids run inhalte zu
kontrollieren
ein haushalt viele systeme der
kühlschrank vom hersteller iks die
waschmaschine vom hersteller y
bei avatar michael alles kein problem
also wir zeigen ja hier ein
zukunftsszenario so wie es in zukunft
aussehen könnte diese einzelnen lösungen
gibt es schon auch diese waschmaschine
dort kann beispielsweise wenn das
waschpulver leer ist erkennt die das und
kann automatisch nachbestellen
der nachteil für den kunden ist im
moment noch dass er für jedes system
eine eigene app auch und das heißt man
möchte eigentlich ein system haben über
das alles abgewickelt wird
der käufer will möglichst alles aus
einer hand aber gläserne kunde möchte
auch nicht sein
das thema datenschutz spielt schon vor
betreten des supermarktes eine rolle
auch auf dem weg zum einkauf der zukunft
ist es ein bisschen wie früher man
wartet auf den bus
womit kann ich mir denn die zeit
vertreiben also auch hier hat man wieder
neue technologische möglichkeiten und
zwar sehen wir hier einmal so einen
digitalen promoter
was sind digitaler pro motor wie ein
interaktives plakat produkte im detail
nicht nur ansehen sondern direkt kaufen
können alles öffentlich an der
haltestelle eine unterwäsche würde man
vielleicht hier nicht kaufen aber auch
für diejenigen die sich um den
datenschutz sorgen machen wenn wir jetzt
mal sagen wir wollen diese socken in
grau kaufen dann sehen wir hier eine
coiffeuse
das heißt man ist hier nicht in der
situation dass man sensible daten von
sich preisgeben muss sondern man es
kennt diesen code beispielsweise mit dem
smartphone ab und schließt dann den kauf
auf seinem eigenen endgerät also es geht
ja letztendlich auch um schnelligkeit
und effizienz und dem kunden die
möglichkeit zu geben seine zeit auch
noch für andere dinge als nur das
einkaufen zu benutzen
ok ich glaube der bus kommt eh nicht
mehr deswegen gehen wir jetzt zu fuß in
den shop und kaufen endlich mal ein gut
ich finde jetzt so viel anders als der
supermarkt den ich heute schon kenne
sieht es jetzt hier nicht aus aber jetzt
sehe ich gerade hier habe ich hier schon
coupon gekommen
der ist jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich genau
abgestimmt auf meinen kollegen michael
auf meinen avatar das heißt das system
weiß schon eine ganze menge über mich
oder genauso wir haben hier einen kupon
über 30 prozent für duschgel bekommen
die frage ist ja warum bekommt jetzt der
michael auf gerechnet so ein duschgel
ausgespielt und zwar funktioniert das
folgendermaßen michael hat auf seinem
smartphone die händler wir sind ja hier
im shop hat er die shop händler app
installiert und diese händler app kennt
natürlich seine kaufhistorie und
errechnet basierend auf seinen vater
oder sein käufen aus der vergangenheit
berechnet künstliche intelligenz
beispielsweise was könnten jetzt für
michael interessante produkte seien und
für diese interessanten produkte gibt es
dann so ein kupon um natürlich ein
kaufanreiz auszulösen
die firmen wissen auch jede menge über
mich das heißt schon so der voll
überwachte kunde oder der gläserne kunde
wie man sagt ja man stimmt dem ganzen ja
auch in einer art und weise zu also
voraussetzungen damit das funktioniert
es erst mal dass die händler app
installiert ist dann dass man innerhalb
der händler app zugestimmt hat und dass
man sein smartphone überhaupt draußen
hat bei diesem smartphone muss ja von
dem bieten also über der eingangstür im
supermarkt das dann ein bieten
installiert das ist eine technologie die
informationen senden und erkennen kann
und über diese bieten technologie wird
dann das smartphone erkannt und nur wenn
all diese faktoren die ich gerade
genannt habe gegeben sind kann der kupon
überhaupt ausgespielt werden das heißt
da sind schon noch hürden dazwischen und
auch hürden die der kunde beeinflussen
kann
viele informationen werden gesammelt
über den kunden genauso wie für den
kunden der wird schließlich auch wissen
woher die produkte kommen preis herkunft
anbau per qr code kann die gesamte
lieferkette zurückverfolgt werden
viele supermärkte bieten dies schon an
technisch ist natürlich noch viel mehr
möglich beim einkauf besonders in
deutschland sind jedoch viele kunden
skeptisch und datenschützer warnen hier
im supermarkt der zukunft kann sich eine
menge erfahren wie es vielleicht in
zukunft aussieht im handel aber sind sie
sich da eigentlich so sicher dass der
konsument das später auch alles mal so
haben will
wir wollen hier auch kein idealbild
zeigen sondern wir wollen
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten aufzeigen
und auch aktiv mit den kunden
diskutieren was könnt ihr euch als
shopper denn überhaupt vorstellen wo
liegen die mehrwerte und wichtig ist
glaube ich dass man ausprobiert und den
kunden auch fragt was der kunde nicht
auf probiert das kann er auch nicht
verstehen und wir konnten uns ja vor ein
paar jahren auch nicht vorstellen was
ein iphone ist also steve jobs hat ja
auch niemanden gefragt hättet ihr gerne
ein iphone sondern er hat versucht vom
kunden her zu denken und sich zu
überlegen was der kunde möchte der kunde
will es vor allem einfach denn einkaufen
ist im alltag oft eher stress als
vergnügen
daher wird auch mobiles bezahlen mit dem
smartphone in deutschland immer
beliebter und in zukunft gut jetzt haben
wir sehr viel neue technik im supermarkt
der zukunft gesehen
das heißt wir müssen eine stunde noch
bezahlen nur weil wir jetzt nichts
gekauft haben oder also auch wenn wir
jetzt ein paar produkte im einkaufswagen
hätten wir haben hier ein anderes system
verbaut und müssen gar nicht an der
regulären kasse bezahlen ja kommen sie
nur raus sagt er mir auch bezahlt vielen
dank für den einkauf ist ja schön aber
ich habe nicht mal ein barcode irgendwo
dran gehalten wie gegners genau das zum
beispiel von einem komplett kastenlosen
einkauf wir haben uns ja als verein
gegangen
eingeloggt das heißt der händler weiß ja
dass wir jetzt in seinem ladengeschäft
sind und dann greifen bei so einem
kastenlosen einkauf unterschiedlichste
technologien ineinander von der
bilderkennung überbieten über wagen an
den regalen um zu messen ob bestimmte
produkte entnommen wurden und es auch
wichtig dass man nicht nur auf eine
technologie setzt weil man möchte ja
auch vertrauen schaffen wo im system
darf sich fehleranfällig vereins heißt
man hat immer verschiedene technologien
die sich dann auch validieren neue
technik digitalisierung vernetzung neuer
konsum auch ein thema beim future day in
frankfurt
denn unser einkaufsverhalten wird die
zukunft unserer wirtschaft unserer
arbeit und unserer umwelt maßgeblich
beeinflussen
der mensch isst und trinkt aber darüber
hinaus wie wird der konsum der zukunft
aussehen
herrmann habe ja das ist die frage ob
wir denn überhaupt noch so als konsum
definieren und wahrnehmen
bei konsum ist ein begriff der ein
bestimmtes kaufverhalten bezeichnet
das ist als endes so dermaßen verbrauch
und wir können eben sehen dass viele ist
das was wir an konsum früher erlebt
haben aneignung von gütern besonders
auch im hochpreisigen bereich vielleicht
eher in richtung auf sharing aufteilen
auf nutzen geht also die die idee des
besitzers hat gewisse bei den
hochpreisigen gütern einbußen
einzunehmen also ich trage zum beispiel
nur jeans eines holländischen
herstellers die ich im abonnement
beziehen ist ein voll biologisch
abbaubar
wenn sie kaputt sind schicke ich sie
zurück dann wird neue jeans daraus
gemacht also solche elemente vor allen
dingen aus der grünen und ökologischen
fragestellungen bei den auto spielt ist
ja auch eine große rolle ist mit
sicherheit wird an bedeutung weiter
zunehmen die zweite große baustelle wenn
man
will des konsums ist ja die
digitalisierung und da können wir eben
auch sehen wie die starken zuwächse von
digitalisierten konsum jetzt langsam so
auch in so eine reifephase kommen
manches ist praktisch gar nicht
digitalisiert war also nahrungsmittel
der mensch ist ein marktwesen ich glaube
dass die märkte wo man die dinge
anfassen kann riechen schmecken kann
testen kann dass sie sogar noch größer
werden und noch also das analoge
kaufverhalten sogar noch interessanter
wird weil man immer mehr von dingen die
man eigentlich so aus funktionalen
gründen braucht ja übers internet
bestellt also es gibt eine aufspaltung
des konsums in diese verschiedenen
richtungen mit einer deutlichen glaube
ich tendenz in richtung auf grüne
fragestellungen das kind aber haben sie
jetzt gesagt vor allem für die
hochpreisigen produkten was ist denn mit
dem markt für die niedrigpreisigen
produkten vor allem was für techniken
werden denn da vielleicht auch das
beeinflussen das konsumentenverhalten
naja also die digitalisierung ist ja
weit fortgeschritten aber ich glaube sie
gerät heute auch an grenzen sie können
den kunden auch nicht unbegrenzt quasi
beobachten und digital bespitzeln ja
also irgendwann geht in die kuh nichts
mehr rein und wir sehen eben wie das
digitale marketing auch langsam anfängt
zu scheitern
interessant ist ja dass auch alte form
von analogie tät er zurückkehren also
denken sie mal an die renaissance der
der vinylplatte also es gibt
offensichtlich auch ein bedürfnis in
dieser vollkommenen überfüllung durch
digitale services leben wieder zu
entkommen durch signifikant
also wir sind alle menschen die auf
irgendeine art von ordnung im hirn
brauchen und wenn sie auf alle musik der
welt zugreifen können das haben wir alle
als erfahrung gemacht sein sind sie
irgendwie nach zwei wochen sollen wirkt
dass sie nicht mehr wissen was sie hören
das ist die entwertung durch das
digitale und das ist glaube ich die
nächste phase wir nennen das auch post
digitale welt wurde oder real digital
das heißt nicht dass digitale techniken
konsum verschwinden aber sie werden
anders re kombiniert
immer mehr shops die so aussehen wie
museen also der neueste trend in den in
den einkaufspassagen und in tokio und
new york sind eben quasi boutiquen bei
dem man auch nicht gekauft sondern die
sind einfach nur als erlebniswelt
ausgeprägt und wenn sie irgendwann da
wir nicht haben dann lass mich nach
hause liefern da den sie nicht an
irgendeine kasse
das ist das sind glaube ich die formen
die sich so hybrid artig in die welt
bewegen
ansonsten haben wir gewaltige zum ersten
mal glaube ich auch relevante große
punkt um diskussionen über das zu viel
ich glaube es gibt eigentlich eine
immanente krise des konsums wie die
menschen auch spüren
und wenn sie mal so so die großen
nachfragen fragen ja also die leute
zahlen in zukunft eher mehr und da sind
wir wieder bei den dienstleistungen für
ihren guten yogalehrer als vierte für
die 27 ist der handtasche die haben sie
jetzt schon befragen selbst wenn sich in
europa ein weniger ist mehr durchsetzen
sollte der konsum wird für den globalen
handel für die gesamte weltwirtschaft
auch in zukunft eine große rolle spielen
wer arbeit hat kauft ein konsum ist für
manche volkswirtschaft der
wachstumsmotor schlechthin
länder wie china südkorea oder taiwan
produzieren immer mehr hochwertige güter
stecken viel geld in forschung und
entwicklung verfügen über gut
ausgebildete fachkräfte die größte rolle
dabei spielt das reich der mitte der
wirtschaftsplan made in china 20 25 soll
china in schlüsselsektoren zum
weltmarktführer machen e-bikes sind dann
schön teuer aus china nicht ganz so
diese hier kosten zwischen 1000 und 3000
euro auf dem amerikanischen und
europäischen markt
diese e bike firma ist das was made in
china 20 25 wohl bedeuten soll
hier werden qualitativ relativ gute
elektro fahrräder hergestellt
sie sind für chinesische verhältnisse
teuer für europäische nicht
früher stand made in china für billige
ware der großen mengen verkaufen
wir wollen keine massenware wir wollen
gute qualität auf den markt bringen wenn
sich unsere fahrt marken erstmal
etabliert haben dann können wir
vielleicht mehr verkaufen aber vorher
nicht unsere zukunft ist die qualität
nicht quantität elektrofahrräder das ist
nur ein winzig kleiner teilbereich einer
viel größer angelegten strategie die
china zum weltmarktführer machen soll
vor drei jahren schon wurde sie
verkündet in zehn schlüsselbranchen will
china mit dem neuen made in china 20 25
die wirtschaft anführen dazu zählen auch
robotertechnologie schiffbau
elektromobilität
kommunikationstechnologien und energie
technik was der chinesische präsident
mit made in china 20 25 vorantreiben
will ist dem amerikanischen zu viel
donald trump antwortet mit strafzöllen
und handelskrieg es kann eine sehr große
bedrohung sein wenn sie bedenken dass
china vor allem durch unfaire
handelspraktiken staatliche subventionen
einflussnahmen der regierung große
anteile von produktionstechnologien
weltweit von anderen ländern kopiert
oder gestohlen hat das ist eine sehr
große sache und wir sprechen hier über
die führenden sektoren der
weltwirtschaft in den nächsten 10 oder
20 jahren
in manchen bereichen hat china schon
längst die nase vorn
beispiel solarenergie erst joint
ventures dann technologietransfers den
wellen china produziert zahlt dafür mit
der weitergabe von wissen
obendrauf noch offene und versteckte
subventionen produzierte überkapazitäten
der preis wird gedrückt die konkurrenz
vom markt vertrieben
ein neues beispiel die zivile luftfahrt
china baut den größten flughafen der
welt investiert subventioniert auch hier
kauft für viele milliarden von euro
wissen und denkt groß china hat sein
erstes eigenes flugzeug die c919 für
rund 180 passagiere noch kein
ernstzunehmender konkurrent für airbus
boeing und co aber es ist ein anfang
kurzfristig gesehen ist die c919 kein
konkurrent zu den großen
flugzeugherstellern aber langfristig
gesehen ist der chinesische markt
sicherlich groß genug für drei anbieter
warum eigentlich nicht
china hat großes vor ob nun in der
zivilen luftfahrt oder der
elektromobilität autonomes fahren
künstliche intelligenz china schafft
längst fakten die ganze welt sollte die
bedrohung durch mate interner 2025 sehr
ernst nehmen
es ist ein bestreben chinas in den
führenden technologien des nächsten
wirtschaftsraums die vorherrschaft zu
erlangen
dadurch werden sie insgesamt
wirtschaftlich überlegen sein
sei es im produktionsablauf oder bei der
schaffung von arbeitsplätzen und wie ist
das mit den elektrofahrrädern seit gut
zwei jahren erobern auch chinesische
produkte den amerikanischen und
europäischen markt
auch wenn die branche keine direkten
subventionen erhält für die einzelnen
bauteile gilt das nicht
relativ gesehen sind die
herstellungskosten in china definitiv
günstiger als in europa wir können uns
auch wichtige batterien zum beispiel von
panasonic und samsung schicken lassen
und sie dann in china neu aufbereiten
das senkt die kosten aber es sind immer
noch internationale batterie mal unsere
verfahren meist mit samsung panasonic
und lg batterie die eu hat am donnerstag
mit vorläufigen anti dumping maßnahmen
reagiert nach acht monaten intensiver
prüfung müssen die meisten chinesischen
firmen mit 83% anti dumping zölle
rechnen nur 37 prozent für die firma von
henley die zölle sind sein preis dafür
dass china weltmacht nummer 1 werden
will
sein thema ist die ökonomie von morgen
jährlich werden europa china und die usa
auch in den nächsten jahren noch große
wirtschaftsräume sein und auch mit
politisch bedeutend wer aber glaubt die
zukunft planen zu können ist
hoffnungslos nach ihnen die nächsten 50
jahre der wirtschaft werden nicht
dieselben sein wir die letzten 50 jahre
für andré reichel ist das wachstum einer
wirtschaft kein selbstzweck und deshalb
will er wachstum neu denken als post
wachstum eher werden die großen player
sein
20 30 jahren naja zum einen sicherlich
die player die jetzt schon groß sind das
heißt nordamerika die europäische union
und china
sicherlich wird es so sein dass china
durch das starke wachstum der
vergangenheit und das noch zu erwartende
wachstum der zukunft sich deutlich auch
vielleicht nach vorne schieben kann aber
man darf auch die usa nicht
unterschätzen auch da gibt es weiterhin
natürlich wachstumsprozesse es kommen
natürlich andere players hin zu indien
zb die sicherlich auch damit ihr
politisches gewicht
wenn es aber bei dieser sache keine
großen veränderungen gibt wenn also die
player dieselben bleiben wird das auch
für die firmen gelten moment sind apple
google facebook sind so die firmen die
jeder auf der welt kennt die auch die
welt mitbestimmen sozusagen werden die
auch weiter so stark am markt seien in
der zukunft was ich gerade sehe ist dass
wir in einer ähnlichen situation sind
die vielleicht anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts in den usa wo wir auf
einmal große marktbeherrschende
unternehmen haben von denen man annimmt
das wird immer so weitergehen aber 20
jahre später mit den anti trust gesetz
in den usa hat sich die
unternehmenslandschaft auch verändert
und ich gehe davon aus dass wir auch in
den nächsten 20 jahren bisher haben
regulat einige veränderungen autobahn
hinbekommen werden so dass diese
unternehmen jetzt nicht vielleicht
verschwinden aber doch sich
wahrscheinlich auf ganz andere umfeld
einstellen müssen vor allem denke ich
dass die europäische union hier sehr
stark regula tour bestritten wird
sie haben jetzt geschrieben das sie sich
wünschen würden dass auch im digitalen
bereich eine gewisse form der
nachhaltigkeit einsetzen würde was
meinen sie denn bislang wird diese diese
digitalisierungs trend dem heer unter
technisch und wirtschaftlichen aspekten
betrachtet und die hoffnung dass wenn
wir digitale technologien überall
einsetzen das ist eine innovation zum
wachstum zu beschäftigung potenziale
gibt und das auch vielleicht
nachhaltigkeitsziele damit viel besser
erreicht werden können man denke an so
sachen wie nachhaltige mobilität
intelligente mobile steuerung
energieversorgung aber was immer
übersehen wird ist dass diese digitalen
produkte einen unglaublich großen
material
und energetischen fußabdruck haben da
wird ja ganz viel wenn ihr ganz viele
edelmetalle und seltene erden verwendet
damit diese produkte überhaupt da sind
und wir brauchen eine unmenge an mehr
strom für künstliche williams für
autonomes fahren für all diese
anwendungen und das wird immer
unterbelichtet also ja es gibt
potenziale auch in richtung
nachhaltigkeit aber es gibt doch viele
nicht nachhaltig keiten die jetzt schon
deutlich sind das heißt also ein grünes
wachstum kann es im prinzip nicht geben
weil immer doch ressourcen verbraucht
werden brauchen wir dann eine host
wachstums ökonomie ich freue mich
natürlich wenn das wachstum etwas grüner
wird das heißt ressourcen und energie
effizienter sich gestalten lässt das
wird auch ganz notwendig sein wenn wir
an entwicklungen wie indien vor genannt
hat ins auge fassen
aber ich denke auch dass man etwas
vorsichtig sein muss die hoffnungen
komplett was das thema nachhaltigkeit
ökologie ökonomie angeht auf das grüne
wachstum setzt wir wissen dass jede
effizienzsteigerung rebound effekte hat
das heißt wenn etwas effizienter wird
wird es ja auch günstige und das erzeugt
meistens mehr konsum und mehr verbrauch
das heißt es interessierten mehr
wachstum und auch der umwelt gebraucht
insofern glaube ich muss man auch sich
auf andere themen fokussieren nämlich
wie kann man die wird wirtschaft
insgesamt aber auch die gesellschaft
weniger wachstums abhängig machen wenn
die welt weniger wachstums abhängig wäre
um sich eine post wachstums ökonomie
durchsetzen würde wie würde sich das
auswirken auf das leben der menschen
beziehungsweise wie würde sich denn die
wirtschaft dann entwickeln weil sie
heute einen völlig anderen modell
funktioniert also ich glaube der größte
größte
hindernis oder die größte
herausforderung ist vielleicht zunächst
gar nicht mal so sehr im
wirtschaftlichen
aber in der frage wie wir die
politischen und sozialen systeme
eigentlich darauf einstellen
im moment sind viele zb in deutschland
unsere sozialversicherungssysteme
basieren ja dass in zukunft die
einkommen steigen durch wachstumseffekte
wenn jetzt die einkommen aber nicht mehr
so stark steigen oder vielleicht
irgendwann überhaupt nicht mehr oder
eventuell sogar mal zurückgehen sollten
dann funktioniert unser
sozialversicherungssystem so nicht mehr
das heißt man müsste eigentlich auch
hier politisch andere rahmenbedingungen
setzen um hier weniger abhängig zu
werden vom wachstum und das einfachste
ist zum einen ressourcen besteuerung
ressourcen würden immer verbraucht
werden
+ vermögensbesteuerung nach vermögen die
akkumulieren auch insofern ist es eine
stabile finanzierung für die
sozialversicherung die auch wachstums
unabhängige eigentlich ist wie also wird
unsere welt in zukunft aussehen wie
leben wir arbeiten dir was essen und was
trinken wir viele fragen wir werden
weiter versuchen sie zu beantworten
auf unserem weg in die zukunft
welches jahr 20 47 würde ich sagen da
war ich nämlich flugs gruppe platte
haben
[Musik]